good afternoon -- the rules
committee for money March
fourth is hereby called
order please be advised
and audio video recording
today's proceedings being
made this also be televised
-- out of sector please call
the roll Cooley Cunningham
Carillo flora Grayson
Kamlager-Dove yeah Maienschein
at this year quirk Silva
Ramos previous yeah
Wicks Carillo yeah
we have a quorum -- and we
have a consent agenda is our
motion on the consent agenda
movers Cunningham second
by Mister Mathis -- that
center please call Cooley hi
I Cunningham
I Carillo no I've flora
Lara I agree Senate race and I
Kamlager-Dove Kamlager-Dove I
Maienschein Mathis Mathis
aye quirk Silva quirk Silva
I Ramos select from us I
riverside ri fest I Wicks hi
Wicks I passed the motion is
passed and -- the rules